winners and losers so far in free agency
shireen give me one that stands out for
you
and why as a winner well i'm gonna start
right there mike i mean why
wouldn't you want to go to tampa if you
had the choice to go play with tom brady
go play with gronk i mean
you see that video you're like i'm all
in i want to go there and i've lived in
tampa i covered the buccaneers for six
years it's a great place to live and hey
by the way no state income tax
but i think the bucks had a terrific
offseason probably the best offseason of
any team because they were able to keep
their guys intact
they got a chance to run it back again
next year with the team they have
chris godwin with the tag they re-signed
shaq barrett lavonte david gronkowski
ryan suck up they still could get
leonard fournette and a b
back if they want to do that i saw ab
over the weekend said hey you know don't
give up on us we may go back there too
so
it's going to be fun to see what these
bucks can do next year because they're
going to have all the pieces in place
or most of the pieces in place that they
had this year i never in a million years
thought they'd be able to do that mike i
thought they would either lose chris
godwin or shaq barrett for sure
i think in any other year they wouldn't
have been able to do it this year you
didn't see a lot of
spending just for the sake of spending
business decisions manifesting
themselves in football moves
this year it feels like all of the moves
have been football related not
hey we want to hold up someone's jersey
and sell tickets although in
jacksonville i kind of think they've
done
some of that for the most part it hasn't
happened and that's what kept a team
from offering shaq barrett more money
than the buccaneers
could or would pay 17 million per year
base value on that deal
10 million per year 10 million less than
the top of the market
what the chargers paid to joey bosa last
year so
they benefited from this weird strange
unusual year that the nfl is
experiencing in my first winter
a team with clear connections to the
tampa bay buccaneers at least as it
relates to guys like tom brady and rob
gronkowski
the new england patriots they've
benefited from this crazy
year by deliberately holding back cap
space 69 million is what they had and as
robert kraft told peter king for
football morning in america they decided
this is what they were going to do and i
love this quote
we always made fun of the teams that
spent a lot in the off season
so uh we know that nothing is guaranteed
and i'm very cognizant of that so they
made fun of teams who do what they're
doing now
they're doing it now strategically
they're doing it because it's the right
way to go
and you know the issue they have with
drafting and developing players
you don't need to worry about it if you
get guys who are already developed and
guys that you believe in and guys who
can come in and hit the ground
sprinting and that's what they're doing
it's it's one hell of an experiment
it's either going to be exactly what the
patriots need or it's going to be a
glorious disaster either way
it's a hell of a story and 20 years of
excellence
in new england leads me to bet on the
side of it working
and them knowing exactly what they're
doing and signing these guys sharing
you know what it all goes back to mike
though is
how good or bad at this point cam newton
plays because he is their starting
quarterback maybe they still go
find another starting quarterback but as
of right now it's cam newton and to me
it's still
all on his shoulders i think they have a
better team
but it's still all on his shoulders of
all the
patriots signings and or trades they've
done a ton of them who do you think is
the best
move that they made well i mean i like
the tight end
acquisitions johnny smith and hunter
henry because that's what's been so
glaring for them and it feels like
they've been struggling to get back to
that point
especially as as uh you know is clear
with what they like to do multiple
formations
pedal to the metal go to a no huddle
offense when you can catch
the defense in unfavorable matchups by
moving these guys around who can do a
lot of different things
and that's what really creates the the
potential for mismatches and can allow
cam newton to grow in that offense if he
ends up being the starter but this team
is better now and they were seven and
nine
with a roster that was overmatched still
seven and nine people think they were
three and thirteen they were seven and
nine they're in position
to make things happen the afc east is
going to be very competitive this year
and the patriots are a team
that you can never completely overlook
because of bill belichick and company
with these better players that they're
going to plug right in
they're going to be ready when tom brady
and company come to town this year when
the buccaneers faced the patriots in one
of the biggest games of the season
and that game got even bigger with what
the patriots did last week all right
give me another winner
i'm going to go with washington mike and
you know i think
they didn't see the quarterback market
develop like they wanted they didn't see
that when they
couldn't get in on matthew stafford they
said all right we're not getting our
quarterback this year unless it's in the
draft and he can sit so we're going to
go sign ryan fitzpatrick he's going to
be our bridge quarterback we also have
kyle allen who we really like
taylor heineke who we really like so i
think they
like their quarterback situation in that
now they can go
in the off season or if they like one of
the guys if somebody falls to him in
this draft they can draft and
groom him to be their future quarterback
but you know they brandon sharif they
they tagged him they resigned dusk and
hopkins
and they got uh william jackson and
curtis samuel i thought curtis samuel
was one of the best receivers out there
for what he can do because he can do so
many different things for you so i like
what washington did
to me they're still at the top of the
nfc
east right now i would put them right
there at the top of the nfc so we know
the division is not very good that's not
saying a lot but i still would cast them
as the favorite right now mike
yeah i agree with you and they just seem
to be systematically
gradually getting better and getting the
kind of players they want and we'll see
where it goes
as this season approaches will it be
ryan fitzpatrick will they will they
stumble into somebody
with their first round pick that they
decide becomes the
the tuatanga viloa to fitzpatrick's
veteran potential backup
relief pitcher as the season approaches
for me dak prescott was a big winner and
i don't think he had any idea
what was coming you know in hindsight
i just i can't help but wonder if the
cowboys
hadn't franchised tag dak prescott
and and had allowed him to become a free
agent do you really think someone else
would offer him
four years 160 million dollars sight
unseen
with that ankle that only the cowboys
know at this point
is in sufficiently good condition it's a
hell of a lot of money to commit
and i don't think
that if yeah all the praise of jerry
shireen for oh he oh he paid all that
money because
he he he alone knew that these tv
contracts are coming
bull crap everybody knew the tv
contracts were coming
what really would have impressed me is
if someone in dallas would have said you
know what
the free agency market this year is
going to suck
and no one's gonna offer him what he
wants
let's just let him become a free agent
let's let's call his bluff
let's see if he would go take less than
what we're offering right now
from some other team like the jaguars
let's go ahead if he wants to do it go
ahead
we'll find another quarterback i i i
think shireen if they had done i hadn't
really thought of that until just now
and it's easy for me to say because i'm
not the one who would potentially be
losing my franchise quarterback
but i i think if they let him become a
free agent they probably would have got
him for less than what they paid him
well and i said that at the time mike
i'm not gonna be surprised if they don't
franchise and let him do that because if
you're another team
are you gonna be all in and give him all
that money without knowing where that
ankle is you're not going to know about
that ankle until the end of april early
may
so it's not like you can go give the guy
a physical and say hey run for us let's
see how you do
you're not going to know so to commit
that type of money to dak prescott
at that time if you're another team to
me would have been a huge gamble now
i think somebody would have tried i do
think there would have been a team out
there that would have gambled say a
washington they actually offered amari
cooper last year more money than the
cowboys did and amari went back to
cowboys he didn't have the injury
problem that dak prescott now has and he
was healthy at the time
but i do think there would have been a
team that would have rolled the dice
would they have given him that much
i don't know that that that's the
question that we'll never be able to
yeah we'll never know the answer to that
question but i it very well could have
happened where he wouldn't have gotten
that much money
all right give me a loser i think i'm
going to start with the texans and this
is clearly a rebuild even though they've
said
that it's not a rebill but you start
looking at all the acquisitions again
i've lost count i know it's over 30
but i don't know exactly what it is if
it's 31 32 or 35 but
somewhere in the low 30s or the players
they've acquired you can't build a team
like that and a lot of these
guys are one year and out the door this
is a total rebuild for this team who
knows who their quarterback's gonna
be right now it looks like it's tyrod
taylor right with ryan finley as his
backup
two more acquisitions but it's gonna be
tough because they're gonna have no on
field we think no
on field participation in in the off
season again so i don't know how you get
take 30 players of your 53 or whatever
it's going to work out to be and expect
them to be good this year mike
yeah i i agree uh with that and they
continue to be
in a tough tough situation the chiefs
are a team that i'm going to put in the
loser category
just because of really two no three
things
one they wanted trent williams patrick
mahomes got directly involved in
recruiting trent williams
trent williams chose to stay with the
49ers two
they wanted juju smith schuster yes they
got involved late in a tug of war
between the steelers and the ravens
these are the chiefs these are the
chiefs this is patrick mahomes
juju how do you not want to go play with
patrick mahomes
juju said no oh for two and then most
recently josh reynolds who
josh reynolds the chiefs tried to get
josh reynolds and he went to the titans
oh for three with guys that they wanted
now i know they got joe tooney and they
paid him a lot of money
but to have these other players this
idea that the chiefs are this
destination team this
super team that everyone's going to want
to play for and i want to go play for
patrick mahomes
i think this shines off that shireen
pretty loudly and pretty clearly
yeah it's a great point mike and and
then it looks like they could lose sami
watkins too he's going to take a couple
visits here
so doesn't sound like that he's a guy
they wanted to to keep they wanted
another receiver to bring in here that
they thought was an upgrade and that
hasn't happened yet so we'll see what
happens with these chiefs but i think
clearly
the buccaneers with what they've been
able to do this off season have been a
winner over what the chiefs have been
able to do
all right give me one more loser real
quick i'm gonna go with the receivers
mike and i just think these guys
expected a bigger market than what they
got you wrote about kenny galladay today
and it looked like the
giants probably bid against themselves
and he got a
good deal but you look at juju smith
schuster signed a one-year deal willful
or one-year deal
i know these guys expected a lot more
money on the market than what they got
there's a lot of guys still out there ty
hilton sammy watkins
a b still out there a lot of receivers
still looking for deals mike
yeah and the last one for me running
backs running backs not getting paid
we're not surprised that running backs
don't get paid a ton of money but this
year it's aaron jones
and then yeah yeah kenny and drake right
but but but aaron jones is the only one
that got big money and
so many of these guys with recognizable
names one year and two year deals that
don't pay very much
at all that that's not atypical but this
year it's even more pronounced
these guys that that we love to have on
our fantasy teams and we pay attention
to their yardage and their touchdowns
every week
once they become free agents teams look
elsewhere to replace them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports